welcome to web scraping with Python my
name is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's WW simply learn comm
get certified get ahead certainly there
are many reasons to be able to go online
and scrape different websites they range
everything from pulling out different
links to pulling data off of websites
it's a data scientist you might need to
get some information off a website that
doesn't have a direct API to pull that
information and in python we have a
wonderful tool when you talk python and
you talk web scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your Python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
w wrff you can actually be a little bit
about it currently beautifulsoup
four is the current version if you don't
remember the full website for it you can
always do what I do which is go over and
do a search for beautifulsoup official
site it almost always comes up right at
the top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy comm software
site for beautifulsoup now we're gonna
use our whatever Python interface you
want IDE I'm gonna use Jupiter lab which
is built on Jupiter notebook through
anaconda so when I open up my anaconda
navigator you'll see that I have my
different tools available again you
might be using a different editor and
that's okay you might be in pycharm or
something like that we don't need to do
this and jupiter lab is jupiter notebook
with added tabs and some added futures
it's basically in beta testing so it's
got a few little glitches when you're
saving things and moving between
projects but for the most part it's a
great upgrade to the jupiter notebook
and you can use them together so you
don't have to I mean it's built on
jupiter notebooks anything you do in
jupiter notebook you can open up in
jupiter lab and the first thing we need
to do is we need to go ahead and in this
case i'm going under my environments
since it partitions the environments out
and i'm gonna open up a terminal window
we have to install some packages in here
to work with now there's a lot of
choices on this i because of the
simplicity we'll be using conduct
install now you can use pip install for
the same thing and we're gonna install
our beautiful soup 4 and you have to
type out the whole thing beautiful soup
4 and you can use a pip install if
you're using a different environment and
I am using Python version
three-point-six although according to
beautifulsoup they also work on 3/7 all
the way from 2/7 through all of 3x now
according to the beautifulsoup website
the beautiful soup for works on anything
you can install anything from Python to
7 all the way through any of the Python
3 versions this just happens to be
Python 3 6 because they do it there's a
lot of other packages and don't work on
3 7 yet and we'll go ahead and run this
install on here and let it go through
its environmental setup and of course
with conda it goes in there and finds
all the dependencies pip doesn't do as
much as far as finding dependencies but
you know exactly what's on there with
pip so if you're doing a huge
distribution you probably want to use
your pip install so you can track what's
going on there with the condom I like to
just let it take over since this isn't a
major distributed package going out
another quick note between pip and Conda
is that if you start on a project at one
of these environments and you're using
pip in there stick with pip if you're
using Conda stick with Conda they
tracked the packages and you can run
into some issues where they're not
tracking the same packages and something
gets overwritten so it's important to
stay very consistent with your install
on your environments and will also need
to go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply install pandas a couple more
packages in this case is get our install
our map plot library because we're going
to plot at the end since we're gonna be
collecting data and for this project
that will be all the packages we'll need
so we can go ahead and close out of our
installer or whatever setup you have and
we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our Jupiter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now if
you're coming from Jupiter notebooks the
first time in lab we can go ahead and
just create our first notebook Python 3
you can also do it under file launcher
and you'll see a new notebook and I make
the opens up and just click right on
there it'll pop open on the left and
I'll right-click this and we'll rename
this will rename it just beautiful
and it is a I PI in B file on there so I
should look from
because that's the Jupiter notebook file
this is a new one now I have more tabs
in the past I usually hid this on the
other computer all my notes for the
lesson today but this is my nose going
down and we'll go ahead and just start
going through this and see what it looks
like to do a data poll from front to end
and see how that works as a data
scientist pulling that information in
from the website and the first thing I
want to do is I want to go ahead and
close a side window that way it looks
get the nice full screen we can also up
the size a little bit one of the
wonderful things about working in a
browser window just do that ctrl+ thing
the packages we talked about is pandas
so we imported our pen as if you haven't
already that's our data frame if you
haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of the time to go
through there and understand pandas it's
such a powerful tool this basically
turns your data into a spreadsheet data
frame our numpy is our number array so
it kind of works with pandas very
closely as far as manipulating data in a
raised mat plot we want to go ahead and
bring that in our PLT so that we can
plot the data at the end and this line
right here that says mat plot library in
line is for the jupiter notebook
specifically it tells it to print that
on this page a lot of the newer versions
don't actually require to have that line
you'll still print it on the page we
should still include that if you're in
the jupiter lab and set up and then we
have our URL library dot request we're
going to import URL open for opening up
the website and then we have our bs4
that's your beautiful soup for we're
going to import beautiful soup and then
our last one is our re that is for
manipulating our regular expressions so
we get to that part of importing our
data we have to do a lot of reformatting
so it's something we can use and the re
is one of those tools we'll go ahead and
run this and just bring all that in so
this is all imported all these packages
are now into our web scraping program
we're gonna right now if we're going to
dive in and pull data we should have a
nice website to pull from and let's go
ahead and we'll use the upper timing
comm results for the 2018 martin luther
king race and if we take this you can
actually just take this where did we get
this from well you can go in here and
find the website your
scrape from and you'll see right here
says you just copy that link right in
there that HTTP and this is a website
that we're looking at you can see right
here all the information that we're
looking at let's see we wondered who
runs some statistics on this it sure
would be nice to be able to pull it off
of here and if they don't have a direct
API that means we need to pull it from
their website some of these will have a
download although if you've ever done we
have a download click and maybe you're
paging through a hundred websites in one
case I was pulling all the different
United States bills that are passed to
track who voted on them for a project
and you can imagine that there's you
know hundreds and hundreds of those
thousands of these documents that they
voted on who voted on it goes to the
Senate goes back to the Congress so I
opened up a website pull all the links
off of there that matched a certain
criteria and we'll look at that in just
a minute how we go through the HTML and
then I had to reformat them or I could
hand download each one one at a time
which would just be a nightmare so it's
nice to automate it in this case we're
gonna be pulling up this chart and we
want to figure out how to pull this
chart off of this website and so we go
back into our Jupiter notebook I've got
my URL just our name for it and it's
just a string that's all this is nothing
fancy there you'll notice it on the
slashes we now have forward forward
slash you can do a single forward and
the HDP is a double forward this is just
you have to switch it to match set up in
there and then it's gonna go ahead and
use the HTML equals URL open URL and
that's from our URL library request so
it's opening a link to that website or
at least pointing to it and if we run
this this just sets it up so this is all
set up and then once we've done our
setup let's go ahead and create an
object called soup this will be and if
you remember up here here's our
beautiful soup that we imported from the
bs4 and this is the package that we're
working with and so we're gonna do our
beautiful soup on here and on this we
need to go ahead and send it our HTML so
it knows what it's opening and then the
second part is we have to tell it how
the format is coming in and the most
common one for your HTML polls is an El
XML setup and so almost all of them
you'll you'll end up using the El XML
there's a few other options and because
this is so common in
newer versions a lot of times they just
leave it out just because it's already
on the default well go ahead and leave
it in here just to remind us that it's
there and we'll go ahead and run that
and on the newer versions they actually
default it to the XML setup in the HTML
we'll just leave it out and call it HTML
so it's just gonna pull from this URL
and when we run that on here we've now
created an object soup that has pulled
the website into it so soup contains the
information along with information on
that website and what's going on
so let's discover what we did real quick
before we start digging into the actual
soup before we start scooping out stuff
we imported our different modules that
we're gonna use with our package
specifically the beautiful soup we did
install the beautiful soup remember
correctly you have to call it beautiful
soup for specifically so it knows what
you're bringing in and this line right
here is very key from the S Fork that's
how installs a module we're importing
our beautiful soup and then we found our
URL in this case we're gonna go pull
information from the martin luther king
dream run and then we set our HTML to
our URL open URL and you can see right
here we imported that so here's our URL
dot request import URL open so we're
requesting a connection and once we send
that connection into the beautifulsoup
it creates an object called soup and
then this one of course we chose soup
just because it goes with beautiful soup
i guess we could have chosen beautiful
and now we can start extracting
information from our website because we
pulled it down on to our computer under
soup we can start by looking at the
title of the website soup that title and
if we print title dot text you'll see
this a lot in beautiful suit because
title contains all kinds of information
and if we want just the text from that
title you had the dot text on the end
and you can see right here we have our
2018 MLK dream run 5k race results if
you look at the tab that's the actual
title up here 2018 MLK dream run 5k race
that's what the title is on the website
and then you might be curious what's in
title what's the whole title that is
storing up there well let's go ahead and
print it out here's print title and
print title dot text and we run that you
can see it has the HTML tags title on it
and then the forward slash title
to end it and so we're really just
pulling off this piece of the HTML code
and then we look at the text inside that
particular part of the HTML and earlier
I mentioned links what if you want to
get all the links off this page well
that would be fun we could do soup dot
well do find underscore all put this in
bracket and then quotation marks we're
going to put a a is the key find and
you'll start seeing a div and all the
different options you have for finding
these entities in a website and then
let's go ahead just print our links and
you can see here that it now shows all
the different links in here that are
marked by eggs we did to find all a and
then we can also because this is a
little bit hard to pull off the H
reference so we can also add in our find
all fine-tune that in this case the H
reference equals true will actually
filter that out and then finally we
might do a for link in links and we can
simply do something like this for each
link we want to actually find the H
reference because we know there's an
each reference in it and if I run this
you can see just comes through and
prints them out one at a time some of
these are really useful so you might be
looking for something that has HTTPS in
it and you know that's a link running to
something else or you might be looking
for the mailto tags you know that's all
the mail addresses but either way you
can easily find all the links in your
HTML document that you're paging through
and of course any packages that have
evolved over time you can also do link
get h reference which should do the same
thing as our other format and you can
see it certainly does we get the same
print out up here in this particular
case we really want to get the data off
the page so let's go ahead and do that
let's see what that looks like and in
data that's call it all rows there we go
equals and then we have our soup dot
fine underscore all there's our brackets
and then if we're looking for each row
in a database you'll remember your HTML
code we're looking for the tag TRS we
want to find all TR and we can take this
and let's go ahead just take all our
rows and do a print all rows and about
this time you're gonna guess it we're
gonna get a huge amount of information
just dumped on to our page and sure
enough we do if you look at this
just kind of goes on forever but this is
an array each row is considered an array
so because of that we can do something
simply as putting brackets and just
print the first let's do the first five
rows so from beginning to five and you
can see here's our first five rows on
here I sometimes like to just do let's
just do rows zero and we see that row 0
is finishers finishers 191 and just out
of curiosity what if that's zero what's
row one male okay so we're starting to
see titles going across here so if we
come up here we do rows we did what up
to ten let's just take a look and see
what ten does again and just take a look
at that information that comes across
place bib name gender age city state
chip chip pace gender and so on so it
comes all the way down here we kind of
have an ending right here and then we
have one and then we actually it looks
like we start to have information so we
have our one or one 1191 max round off
that must be the name male twenty nine
and so on you start seeing how the
information starts getting displayed
going down so the next thing we want to
do with this I'll go back up here and
just edit the space we're in so starts
to make a little bit more sense keep it
all together and so we want to do for
each row in all rows we're looking at
what information are we looking at well
we have our th up here that's a header
RTD down here which looks like the
individual information and we really are
looking for that actual data so we're
looking for our TD tags in the rows and
we can do that because when remember
when it stores a row it also stores the
tags underneath that so all rows have
all the different tags in it and you can
see right here as you print each one of
those out and so we look at each row we
can create another variable we'll call
it row list and we'll set this equal to
this case row because we've already
pulled all the rows out of soup so now
we want to find for each row and in
there we want to find our TD and if we
go ahead and just print I'm gonna do it
if you notice I changed the indent so
I'm just gonna print row list what this
does is the last value to go into row
list our last row is going to print now
and of course make sure you have an
underscore instead of a period when
you're typing so row dot find underscore
all TD and if we print the last row you
can
I have all the data coming across here
we have our 191 our 1216 zuma oak TOA
app I said that right female I believe
that's age 40 and so on and then we can
take our ro list and there's a lot of
things we can do with the ro list but
we'll do four let's do object or let's
just do cell in row list and so we're
gonna look at each cell because this is
if you look at this they have comma
separated between the different objects
and then we're gonna go ahead and print
cell dot text let's just take a look and
see what that looks like and we can see
here for each row being at 191 there's
our 191 there's our twelve sixteen
twelve sixteen are individual who's in
the race and so forth all the way down
for those different settings and let's
go ahead and create a new variable up
here we'll call this all let's just call
it data we'll keep it simple so here's
our data and then we have our row we
take our row we break it up into
individual cells so we'll call this data
row we'll set this empty to an empty row
and we're gonna take our cells tab this
we know that each cell generates a text
and so what we want to do is I want to
take my data row let's just replace that
let's take our data row and that's a pen
our cell dot text so I'm gonna add that
each row is going to be a row of the
different text on here and then once I
create each row I want my data which is
gonna be everything to append each row
and here's our data row and then if we
go ahead and come down here and that's
just print data now if we were lurking
with large data we'd be very careful
about just throwing all our data on the
page but you can see here we throw the
data on the page and we get finishers
199 mel 78 female 1 13 1 and so on and
if you look at this this is the headers
on the file we have finishers male
female it's just like some general
statistics on the first one and then we
have actually an empty data set and then
we have our data that continues which
actually the actual information we're
looking for so we have 111 91 max
Randolph male 29 Washington DC run time
one of 78 and so on on here so we could
really quickly get rid of that number of
different ways to
do that one of them is just to do is set
if we do data to on we should get rid of
everything but we want to keep Randolph
so make sure Randolph is in there we
lost Randolph let's try the one on there
we go there's max Randolph on there so
we can just simply do redo our data on
here and we can do data probably want to
do it in all rows from one on but I'm
just gonna do my data equals data up one
on down here and there's reasons to
split it this way in data science
sometimes you don't want to touch the
original data in case you need it
in case we do need the first row so
we'll put it down here and maybe we'll
just call this titles titles equals data
of zero and so we could do something
here when we print will print up our
titles and we'll print our data in this
case instead of one on let's go - true
let's look at the last two rows of data
so here we have our titles and for some
reason to just put in finishers of 191
is expecting a little bit more up there
and we have our last couple people and
they look like the data on these looks
just fine on here turns out this is just
some generic statistics up here so we'll
get rid of titles completely it doesn't
really do us any good but we know that
data comes in here and we can look at
our data and look at the very end of the
data to the - - to the end and we can
see it pulls the data in pretty good we
don't have anything too funky in here
we're looking at it looks pretty clean
they got to be a little careful because
at some point we might have to come back
here and clean up the data if we get an
error for running data analysis we might
find out there's some unusual characters
or something is miss set in the data
itself you also notice that everything
is a string so when we're bringing it in
we might have to do some conversions to
test it out and convert them to whatever
kind of data format we're working with
so at this time we want to go ahead and
bring in our pandas and let's go ahead
and call this DF for data frame we'll
set it equal to and if you remember
correctly we imported pandas as PD and
that's standard you'll see that in most
code examples or they call it they
import pandas as PD and it is capital D
capital F for data frame and we're just
going to bring in our data that's what
we called it on here and let's take this
and we'll print now when you're working
with data frames you
usually talking large amounts of data
and so you almost never want to print
the whole data frame out we're gonna go
ahead and do that anyway just so we can
see what that looks like and you can see
in here brings in our data frame coming
in here and we just have a mess of
information this is our data let's go
ahead and print DF and see what that
looks like in the data frame and this is
nice because it organizes it into very
easy to read table and we have they set
the label 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 and so on and
then we have each row we have male 78
none and none going across when we get
all the way down here we'll see max
Randall about number 3 and the first
thing this does is this Flags me that I
brought in a bunch of information up
here that we really didn't want
it's from 3 on that we want and we can
clean this up in one of two ways we can
try to clean it up under the data or we
can clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this I want to go ahead
and just change it appear in the actual
data polling we don't need that
information so I'll rerun it reload our
data from 4 on and then when I run this
we see we have max Randolph is right at
the top of the list like you should be
and we have all the data going down now
with the data frame remember I said we
don't usually print the whole data frame
we'll go ahead and do DF head and this
prints the first five rows and you can
see that we have 13 columns
here's max Randall all the way to Theo
Kinmen and I use the also print DF tell
and the reason I like to do these
particular two setups I'm gonna change
it just to two rows because you can do
that you can present many rows as you
want
is this good look at the first part and
the end because those are usually where
you have extra data brought in
something's messed up and you can also
see that we have a hundred 90 rows in
here and it comes in with our zoom
alicia and they're both on here on the
list so now we have a nice data frame
columns and rows we can easily look at
it we can see the set up on here and we
can look at the names and everything now
at some point you might be looking at
these individual columns and find
different information that needs to be
re-edited if you can you try to do it
with the whole column under pandas you
can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row you can look at individual cells
maybe you find a marker
in that cell that's something specific
like remove all colons or semicolons or
something in there are brackets there's
a lot of options in there but you'll
find that this one actually comes in
pretty clean on here all the way down
and the next thing we really want to do
is we want to look at the headers I
don't know about you but doesn't make
any sense to me when I have column 1 I
don't know what 1191 is or 1080 need
name Kaiser runner I'm guessing that's
column - his name's third one it looks
like male or female probably age but I
don't want to guess I want this to bring
in my column so I know exactly what I'm
looking at so how can we make beautiful
soup do that for us well let's take our
column headers we're gonna set that
equal to our soup find underscore all
and then we're gonna look for our
headers our th files and since we're in
Jupiter lab in this case Jupiter
notebook I can just type out column
headers if it's the last variable I have
listed it'll automatically print it just
kind of a shorthand and we can see right
here we have place I'm guessing that's
bib name gender age city state chip time
chip pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there
I shouldn't have to type them all in
I'll go ahead and do it before we'll go
ahead and do a header list equals our
empty array and then we can do for
column in column headers and we can take
our header list and just a pin and what
do we want we want the text from the
column so we'll just do column dot text
and then if we come down here and we
print our header list let's see what
that looks like if we did or right we
should get a nice list of all the
different column headings we want so we
have place bib name and so on and then
pandas just because pandas is so cool we
can simply do DF columns equals our
header from our header list we can
simply said DF columns set to DF headers
and then if I print DF head we'll take a
look at that and we'll see right here it
has nicely placed our values on here
place bib name gender age and so on so
very quickly of creating this nice data
frame we have the data displayed in Nice
rows and columns and easy-to-read
as a data scientist the first thing we
want to know is the info what is in
these columns and rows and headers and
you see right here they all come up with
non null object there's a big flag so if
I want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object I usually mean strings in this
case that there are string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are it's probably good also to look
at the shape of the data D F shape we'll
go ahead and just run that you see it's
191 by 1414 columns under no 91 entries
this is more like a we look at a number
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if I put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells
Jupiter automatically prints it out so
if you're in a different IDE you'd want
to go ahead and use the print statement
on here one of the things you'd want to
also go through create a second one D of
two equal D F dot drop-in ink now the
axis is automatically equal to zero so a
lot of times you'll see something like
X's equals zero comma
how equals any axis equals zero is
default that means we're looking at
going down the rows you could look at
the column going across let's remove the
how inexistence going to confuse you the
axis is is whether you're going down the
columns or if you're looking at a row by
row by row by row or you could be
looking at it by column by column by
column this would drop any column and
they would drop out the n/a in any
column and how equals we want any I
always confuse all in India they both
start with a all means that all of them
have to be non value where any means
that any of them can be there to drop it
so this would drop any column with a
null value in it but we want zero you
know drop any value with a null value
and then because zero is always the
default well just leave it out and then
it's curious as to what the shape is now
did we lose anything
was there any null values in our df2
that we drop from the DF and we'll go
ahead and run that and we see 191 and 14
so we didn't really drop anything but
it's always good to check there's other
ways you can also do
are there any na s you can detect na is
in here no values infinite values that's
another one you gotta watch out for
we're working with data that we're gonna
do something with here in a minute so
you gotta be a little careful also in
the convergence are you gonna convert
something where people typed in weird
characters to describe the data a
certain way so now we've got to this
point where we have all our different
columns we have a different data and at
this point maybe you're asking or maybe
the shareholder the company is asking
hey can we look at the based on the chip
time here's our chip time can we plot
that versus gender how does gender
versus chip time compare and so we can
do that we can take that and the first
thing we look at is we say hey well chip
time came in as a string and that's
going to be an issue now there's a
number of ways you can change this one
of them is we could go all the way back
up here where we created the data and
find a way to tag it and say hey
whenever this cell text maybe instead of
appending this I noticed that anytime
there's two colons in it that's probably
a time signature and let's convert all
the time signatures to date/time field
or whatever a lot of times you don't get
that you don't get that option and
that's always a question in bringing in
data whether you convert the data coming
in at the beginning or do you wait till
you have it open it up and then convert
it when you go to use it we're going to
go ahead and convert it after we get it
into our data frame so we have our df2
here we've dropped all of our na s we
dropped we have a shape in fact let's do
this since there's no difference between
DF + DF - oh we'll just go ahead and use
DF - so let's go ahead and take our DF -
and we want to take those that specific
field and convert it into some kind of
numerical value we can use let's add
another column a lot of times this is
something you want to do is where you
want to go ahead and keep all the
original columns and just add a new
column in there and this new column is
going to be based on the if we remember
correctly we had chip time that's what
we're gonna look at okay we want chip
time versus gender if we go into our
Panda as we find out we have
to Delta and this is actually time Delta
and then we just want to take our d f2
and we're gonna use the chip time column
so this is gonna say hey let's look at
let's convert everything in DF to chip
time into a time Delta format that's the
data type we're gonna put it as let me
go ahead and just run this and if we go
in here we do info DF - and we'll keep
our look at this particular column but
we want to keep it as a data frame so
this is a list of all the columns we
want to look at I'll just do that info
on here and run that and we do an info
on that you can see is now a time delta
64 nanoseconds well we really don't want
nanoseconds we actually probably want to
do it in minutes so let's take a look at
that and let's take this whole thing of
- let's just set the DF - we have our DF
- this is a column we're working with
here and we can use the as type property
in pandas and so we can set this equal
to DF - we'll take our same column in
here
and we'll set it as type time Delta
second so it's still a delta time here
so if I run this you'll see that it
still comes up as where is it well it
turns it into a float so we're now at a
float 64 so it's the number of seconds
in that Delta time and then finally we
want to go ahead and turn that from
seconds to say minutes and you know
there's 60 seconds and minutes and so
now we divide by 60 we still have a
float we have our info it shows us as a
float and then we can go ahead and just
do a print DF - and let's just keep it
small we don't look at all our data we
just want to do the head of it and we
run this and you can see right here
where we go to the last one there's our
chip time in minutes a lot of times just
to make life easy for viewing since
we're looking at this particular element
we can do chip time in minutes and now
we just see the dupes we take off and
take off our info done with that I'll
run this and you can see we have our
minutes sixteen point eight minutes
seventeen point five one minutes and so
on it's float number now keep in mind
this is point eight that's not 16
minutes and 80 seconds they can always
throw you if you're going through so
many numbers you forget so important to
remember that and we're also going to
look at the other
we're looking at is what gender like a
gender to chip time in minutes and so we
can see here under the head we get male
male male and a number of different
setups and this switch this to tail real
quick and just look at the end of it
here we have female female male female
female so we have two different genders
and we have our chip time in minutes if
you remember we brought in our p LT if
you haven't used the plot library the
map plot library you have a drawing
place you're putting stuff on so we have
our p LT we're gonna do a bar graph and
we just want to simply use our d f2
gender and d f2 chip time in minutes so
that's gonna plot the two bars and to
make it pretty we'll go ahead and give
it the X labeled gender the y labeled
chip time minutes and that simply is
remembered always plots X into plots y
we have our gender or chip time give it
a nice title comparison of average
minutes run by male and female and if we
go ahead and run this with the correct
titles in here and everything matches
you'll get a nice graph we can see here
the comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
there's a number of studies that show
that women team tend to have as far as
doing cross-country there's a lot of
women who have a longer endurance than
men so it's not too surprising we can
see here the average chip time around 70
and for women over a hundred minutes
really a really cool thing we can do is
we can describe the data so DF to
describe this again is a panda's
function just like info is we're gonna
include n P number the numpy number if
we run that you'll see here comes up it
says chip time in minutes account it
gives you the average or the mean
standard deviation the minimum the
maximum all the different descriptive
information you're gonna want from your
data set on there and just because
there's all kinds of fun ways let's do a
box plot to display your information we
can do a box plot where the column
equals chip time in minutes let's go
ahead and run that keep mistyping my
chip time in minutes you can see puts
out a nice box plot showing you the
information we have our different values
and floaters this is always interesting
this is a nice way of seeing where we
these floaters one up here and there's
two up above and of course you're there
nice spread on the boxplot and we can
also modify this a little bit and we can
add in by equals gender and then we'll
give it a little just give it a blank
title we'll just add a wide plot why
label on there for run time and if we
run this you can see here box plot group
by gender chip time in minutes and now
we have our female in male two different
areas and you can see how they vary you
have your two different your outlier up
here you can also see how there's such
an overlap between the two different
values so if I was looking at this I'd
be like wow you know I really could not
draw a conclusive thing on this saying
that woman's run time was more in
general because they overlapped too much
that would be one of the conclusions I'd
have to come up with them here and then
we get to maybe the partners come in
from the company and say hey we'd like
to know the age versus chip time in
minutes that'd be something worth
knowing on the statistics on this and
the first thought is we can simply plot
it and we can do this we can actually
plot the scatter plot chip time versus
df2 of age there's our XY coordinates
but if you remember from df2 and we did
the info let's go way back up here we're
looking at a data object as far as our
chip time on this and our age now we
converted the chip time but we also need
to convert the age and if we do it right
here we just plot it and it'll actually
let us plot it it shouldn't you should
give us an error but it does let us plot
it you'll see the ages come up a mess
over here because they're converting it
to weird float numbers and all kinds of
things so what we want to do is we want
to take our age and we'll just call this
age underscore I so we're going to take
our age and we're gonna create another
column for DF - age underscore eye and
the eye is just going to stand for
integer it's our own choice of values
there is a number of ways to do this but
we're gonna do pandas too Marik is the
best way in pandas and the reason we're
doing this is that numeric creates a
float value so right off the bat we want
all our stuff convert and converts it to
the least common denominator so if
they're all integers already you'll get
integers as you can see from here it's
doing some kind of conversion that
converts it to a float value the other
thing that numeric does is if there's an
value or they put in like a blank line
or a dash to represent no information
it'll convert it to a null so it goes
from like a string to a null versus just
having some kind of made-up number that
Python somehow created for the graph we
have below and then we want to add rdf
to age because that's what we're
converting to numeric and then we want
to coerce it and there's a couple
different options on this like you can
have it where it just doesn't process it
in pandas but coerce means that if it
gets a weird value that is a null value
now and since we're dealing with errors
this is what happens when you get an
error converting it we want to coerce it
there we go and put the in bracket on
there and then finally we want to go and
round this off so I'll put brackets
around all the way around it and this
rounds off everything in this series so
we've done here is I've taking DF to H
which is a D type object which is this
case is mostly strings with a couple
blank ones in there and we're gonna
convert it to a numeric which will
automatically go to float and then we're
gonna take wherever there's an error
wherever says hey this doesn't convert
and usually that's a blank screen like I
said I've worked with so many databases
where they someone puts down none
someone types in space some types in a
dash to mean none and you get this
really weird conversion coming up this
covers all of that in pandas so it's
really a nice way of just coercing it
and saying hey if we don't have a number
in there let's make it a null value and
then we're gonna round it off and then
finally let's go ahead and take our DF
to here's our D of two and let's drop
those null values drop na and we want
hao-hao equals any so that means if
there's any null values in the data set
now you can just make it you in trouble
because you might have no values in a
different column and so you might lose
data that way at this point we could
also do like certain parts of like drop
just certain columns with null values
there's all kinds of other options in
here but we're just gonna do how we're
gonna just drop any and we want to do it
in line equals true so that means it's
going to reassign it to DF two so DF 2
now has rounded out so it's rounded to
the integer we didn't do any places the
age and it's gonna be age I and then
we've dropped all our null values that
we were not going to get any errors when
we try to plot a null value and it also
makes sure that data by deleting out the
rows because that's what this does it
does AXI zero which is your Rose axes
one is your columns by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
rolls and then we go ahead and plot this
we see we have a nice clean data and we
have aged all the way up to 70 so we
have our chip time set and then our age
going across and it makes a nice plot
that you can easily show for display and
for the and you can easily show that to
your shareholders or whatever group
you're working on it makes it really
nice and quick easy display and with
that thank you for joining us today you
know for a quick look at the beautiful
soup and the web scraping tools in
Python again thank you for joining us
with simply learn this is w w simply
learn comm get certified get ahead
Richard Kirchner have a good day happy
learning and look to see you in classes
if you have any questions feel free to
post them on the bottom of the YouTube
we do go back and look at those
questions and answer them and you can
also visit us at our website we have a
number of different communities and
forums there where you can ask questions
concerning programming web scraping data
science and just about any kind of
certification program out there you can
imagine hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here